- And I think Xi
sees Putin is sloppy.
I think that he's,
he's looking at
how Putin did this
and he is looking at
Putin made mistakes,
but the way President
Xi is looking at this is
he's very much paying
attention to every country
that's giving Ukraine arms,
he's paying attention
to every company
that's no longer doing
business with Russia.
He's watching what's
happening at the UN,
he's watching how the
world is isolating Russia.
And he is not saying, no,
I'm not gonna do this.
He's saying, okay,
when I do this,
I'm gonna have to
do it differently.
And so it, again,
we can't take our
eyes off of China
because China is gonna be next.
What we need to do is
learn the lessons of Russia
and see what happens
when division comes in,
which is what happened
with us and our allies
when we look distracted,
it opens a door for
these thugs to do,
you know, the devil's work.
And that's exactly
what they're doing.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the former United
States Ambassador
to the United Nations,
the former Governor
of South Carolina
and someone who knows
a little something
about international relations.
Ambassador Nikki Haley, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks so much, it's
great to be with you, Dave.
- Well, I'm glad to
have you this week
because I've been
telling my audience
for the last 10 days or so
that it's extremely
hard right now
to figure out exactly what's
going on in Ukraine and Russia.
And of course, Kamala
Harris did tell us
that Ukraine small, Russia big,
but I wanna see if we
can give a little more
thoughtful analysis
to that if possible.
So first, could you just give us
sort of a Russia-Ukraine 101,
a little bit of the history,
some of the geopolitics,
what got us to this moment
and then we'll go from there.
- Well, I think what
got us to the moment
is we all know that
the Soviet Union fell
and when it fell, you know,
Russia apparently had borders
and Ukraine had
freedom and democracy.
And what has happened
is Putin has decided
he's just gonna ignore history.
He's gonna recreate it.
And in his mind,
he thinks that it needs to
go back to the Soviet Union.
And so he believes that
Ukraine is part of Russia.
It's part of the Soviet empire
and he's only taking what
is rightfully theirs.
Ukraine on the other hand
is a flourishing democracy
where people appreciate freedom.
It was knocking on
Putin's doorstep.
He was worried that Russians
were gonna see the freedom
that Ukraine's,
that Ukrainians had.
And he didn't want
that to happen.
The lesson in all of the Dave is
that when an evil dictator thug
says they're gonna do something,
we need to believe them.
Putin said he was
gonna take Ukraine
and he is.
China said they were gonna
take Hong Kong and they did.
Putin says that he's next going
for Poland and the Baltics,
we should believe him.
China says, they're
going to get you Taiwan.
That's gonna happen.
Iran says, they're gonna
just destroy Israel.
We need to start
understanding that
when tyrants say something,
we should believe them,
get in front of it,
so that we don't see this kind
of bloodshed that's happening
because what's happening now is,
is nothing short of a tragedy.
- Is this one of the things
that we discussed in
our original interview,
say six or eight months ago,
where if we don't,
if the United States
does not lead,
does not say,
'Hey, we have red lines
that you can't cross'
say, 'There are things
that you cannot do'
if we don't do it,
that the world just kind of
goes to hell in the hand basket.
It doesn't mean we do
everything right all the time,
but pretty much without us,
NATO doesn't function,
other countries don't sort
of stand up for what's right?
- Yeah, I think it
was very clear to me
at the United Nations
that whether countries
like the US or not,
they want us to lead.
They would much rather
follow the United States
than follow China or
Russia any day of the week.
And you know, what I saw is
when we speak the world listens,
when we act, the world follows,
who we are, the
world wants to be.
And so it doesn't mean
we have to go to war,
but it means that we need
to speak and speak loudly
and we need to make sure we
do it in the name of freedom
and we do it in
the name of peace.
And what we need to be
saying loudly now is,
you know, Europeans thought
that if they were
nice to Russia,
that Russia would
leave them alone.
And what you find out is when
you sleep with the devil,
the devil owns you.
Europeans became 40%
dependent on Russia,
on Russian oil.
Russia is a one
industry country.
Their whole livelihoods
is surrounded by energy
and the energy industry
and so what Europe has to do
now is they have to become
independent of Russian oil,
Poland and Lithuania
have already done that.
They're getting
theirs from Australia.
The United States should
not be taking Russian oil.
We could open up the
Keystone Pipeline
and that would take up the oil
that we're getting from them.
But also we need to
double down on fracking.
We need to export
liquified natural gas.
We need to really
start to understand
this is a national
security issue
because while a lot of people
think this is just Ukraine,
a million people have
migrated out of Ukraine
into all of those
European countries,
especially Poland right now,
the entire European region
is gonna be disrupted.
And we're all gonna feel that.
And so this is about being smart
and realizing where we are,
and the fact that we need
to be doing something.
If you see the death
that's happening
in the streets of Ukraine,
don't think that's over there.
That very well could be us.
That's not saying, you know,
anytime there's
a free democracy,
there's a tyrant
ready to take it.
We've seen that with
Israel for a long time.
You're now seeing
that with Ukraine,
you're gonna see it with Taiwan.
United States has to figure
out what they wanna be
when they lead.
And I think we are always right
when we lead on the
side of freedom.
- So you briefly
mentioned sanctions there.
I'm sure you saw
the clips last week
where Jen Psaki
basically was saying,
you know, we have these
incredible sanctions,
sanctions like you've
never seen before.
And just hours later,
I think it was our Deputy
Energy Secretary who said,
"Oh, but it won't affect
the energy sector of
Russia's economy."
I mean, do you sense
that the people
that are in charge right now
from Biden to the spokesmen,
to the rest of them,
that they have a sense of really
what's going on here?
- I mean, they're
running scared.
They're running scared.
Either you're gonna be tough
on Putin or you're not.
The only way to
be tough on Putin
is to sanction the
energy companies.
President Zelenskyy of
Ukraine is begging for it.
He's begging for things.
And you know,
are we okay allowing people
to die in the streets of Ukraine
because we're worried
that Russia will get mad
if we sanction
their energy sector?
No, we should be
teaching Russia a lesson
by sanctioning their
energy companies.
We should be pulling them out
of the international
banking system.
We should be sending
arms to Ukraine
so they can defend themselves
and protect themselves.
You know, they desperately
need anti-air, anti-tank,
javelin and stinger missiles.
We should be sending those over.
You know, Zelenskyy has said,
look, you know, send us planes,
send us tanks, send us anything.
And you know, the United States,
if we stepped up and did it,
the rest of the world
would step up and do it.
20 countries now
have provided Ukraine
with all sorts of
military equipment
and things that they need
but I'm worried it's gonna
be too little too late.
- What would you
say to the people
who make the argument that,
okay, so you do everything
you can on sanctions.
We arm the Ukrainians, we
get some real alliance,
worldwide alliance
against Putin,
but this guy does have nukes.
There's questions about,
you know, what his
real motives are
and mental health and
all of that stuff.
That, if we do
basically what you're
laying out there,
that we then,
we just don't know what's
at the end of the road
or that if you pin this guy,
or if you pinned
him into a corner.
- America's never been scared,
we can't be scared now.
What you do is you fight
evil, wherever it exists,
we need strength right now.
If he's gonna do something,
he's gonna do it regardless.
The best thing we can do
is continue to isolate.
Isolate him in the
eyes of the world
and continue to make sure that
we have all of our
ally partners together.
I mean, the thing that
bothers me the most is
where are the Arab countries?
They haven't said a word
through all of this.
This is an oil war.
They should absolutely
be saying something.
You know why they're
not saying anything?
Is they don't trust
that America will lead.
And they don't trust
that Putin will fail.
And so the best thing
United States could do is
step up and lead and kick
Putin where it hurts.
Might he uses nukes?
Yes, but the bigger question is
Ukraine had nuclear production
and there was a
treaty that was done
with US, Russia and Ukraine,
where Ukraine gave up
all of their nukes,
they were the third largest
holder of nuclear arms,
gave up all of their nukes
in the name of being free, in
the name being independent.
What does this say to
countries like Iran?
North Korea?
Those that were saying
they have to denuclearize,
why would they give
up their arms now?
When they know that they really
don't get the protections
they say they're gonna get.
So what you're gonna see is
the world is gonna start going
back to the nuclear arms.
They're gonna start beefing up
because they're worried about
when it's gonna happen to them.
- Did Ukraine just not
understand full geopolitics
and giving up nukes?
I mean, at the end of the day
that you have to be responsible
for your own security,
even if everything
was right in the US
and the world was
really trying to do
the best they could.
At the end of the day,
it still is about you
defending yourself.
- Well, you know,
I think Ukraine
tried to do the right thing.
You know, what they did was,
in the name of peace,
they said, okay,
we won't produce,
we'll give ours up.
But history will now look back
and I think Ukrainians are
probably looking back going,
should we have done that?
And I think now that you know,
the rest of the world's
gonna look at that.
And that's why you're gonna see
all the talks about,
you know, denuclearizing
are gonna be on pause
for a good while.
- So, you know, I'm
with you on the,
you sort of have to have
peace through strength,
but there I do also have
a strong libertarian side
and part of me right now,
and I'm hearing this
from my audience also,
people are just kinda like,
you know, we're so screwed
up in this country right now,
all the woke stuff and
Critical Race Theory
and the border and inflation
and supply chain.
And of course we can relate
some of that back to the energy,
which gets us to Russia.
But that there's just so
many problems right now.
It's like, can't someone
else do something right now.
And I am somewhat
sympathetic to that,
even hearing the arguments.
Like there is part of
me, that's just like,
maybe there's just too
much to chew up right now,
especially because I
just don't have faith
in our are leaders right now.
If we had leaders
that I had faith in,
maybe I would feel a
little bit differently.
- Well, you know,
I've always had a
libertarian streak to me too.
And I think that, you know,
government needs to stay
out of a lot of things
and we would be much better off.
But what I will tell you is,
we always have to
fight for freedom.
And the reason we
fight for freedom
is because it could,
you know, the threats could
end up on our doorstep.
Why should you
care about Ukraine?
You should care about Ukraine
because this was a country
that all they were doing
was mining their own business.
They were trying to be free.
And what you've got
is you've got tyrants
around the world.
I saw this at the
United Nations,
Russian and China
started to get together,
not because they
like each other,
trust each other,
but because the one unifying
thing for both of them
is they wanna destroy the West.
They wanna destroy democracy,
they wanna destroy freedom,
and they're gonna do
whatever they can to do that.
The reason you should
care about Ukraine
is because if Russia
gets away with this,
Taiwan is next
and China will take Taiwan,
it's not if it's when,
and when they do Taiwan
produces, you know,
half of the world's
semiconductor chips.
So for all of your viewers,
if you like your phone,
if you like your computer,
if you like your car,
all these things that
we now electronically
can't live without,
China would literally own us.
We would be in
the same situation
that Europe is with Russia
on the dependency of energy,
we would be in that same
dependency with China.
And China would not be
near as kind as Russia.
I can promise you that.
They're stronger,
they're sleeker,
they're smarter
and they're more are
determined than ever
to ruin the West.
And so these are all places
we have to care about,
because if it's another
country, it could be us.
And we're not saying go to war.
I'll be the first one to say,
as a wife of a combat veteran,
that's a last resort.
What I am saying is use the
power of our voice for good.
Use the fact that we
do have military arms,
that we can send for good,
use the fact that we can
help get our allies together
to become less
dependent on Russia,
so they don't put all of
us in a bad situation.
So that we can really get
more alliances together.
That's all for good.
That's not, you know,
that's not going to war.
That's not getting
government involved.
That's saying we're
gonna protect freedom
and we have to protect
freedom wherever it rains.
- How much of this do you blame
on the Biden administration?
I mean, you were at the
UN under President Trump.
You know, it's not that we
had perfect world peace,
obviously,
but Putin was quiet
when it came to Ukraine.
He did some stuff,
Crimea under Obama,
but there was certainly the
feeling that if he did something
under Trump, who
obviously was like,
well, what would Trump do?
So he didn't do any,
you know, so Putin
didn't make a move.
How much of this do
you blame on Biden?
You mentioned Keystone Pipeline,
I mean, we're reliant
on the bad guys.
This is a problem.
- Biden is, has really,
really done this to all of us.
And I will tell you this
never would've happened
under President Trump.
And it was because
President Trump
really kinda laid it out there
for all the tyrants out there.
But President
Trump did something
that Russia absolutely disliked.
He built up our military,
which Russia never
wanted us to do.
He made sure we were
energy independent,
which Russia didn't like.
And he made sure that he
would not allow Nord Stream 2
to go through,
which was gonna be a big
revenue source for Russia.
But what's happened since then.
President Biden now
comes into office.
He allows Afghanistan to fall,
but not only did
Afghanistan fall,
what they saw was
the United States
left Bagram Air Force base
in the middle of the night
without telling the allies
who stood shoulder to shoulder
with us for two decades,
without telling them
that we were doing it.
Big signal to our enemies,
big signal to our allies.
Then you go forward
and he goes and
waves Nord Stream 2-
a gift for Putin at the
time that he needed it.
Then you add onto that,
Biden's falling all over himself
to get into the Iran deal.
I mean that, the
weakness of that
when Iran wouldn't even
let the US in the room,
Biden's begging to
get back into a deal
with the number one
state sponsor of terror.
And then finally
you see Biden speak
and what does he say?
He says, well, if it's
a minor incursion,
we'll do one thing.
If it's an invasion,
we'll do another.
Those were all green
lights for Putin.
Putin knew that never again,
would we have a weak President
like this in America.
And it's the same thing
President Xi sees in China.
They see it.
They know there's
an opportunity.
Putin chose to move on.
It never would've happened
under President Trump
because there was
never any weakness.
There was deterrence
under President Trump.
- Do you think Putin's
a little surprised
that it seems like the whole
world has rallied around this?
I mean, you know,
they're talking about kicking
him off the SWIFT system
and the sanctioning of the
oligarchs and all of this stuff.
I don't know that it's
gonna work exactly.
But do you think he's
a little surprised
how quickly things came to be,
although they did,
Russia did Veto, their
security council member.
So they veto the UN
security council resolution,
which is sort of
hilarious, I suppose,
in a depressing sense.
- I mean, I think he's
completely taken aback.
I mean, I don't think
that he thought that,
you know, that he was gonna
see this much resistance.
I don't think he thought
that President Zelenskyy would
become this much of a hero.
I don't think he knew the
courage and inspiration
that the Ukrainian people
would be to the world.
And so, you know,
what you've got is
Ukrainians picking up
knives from their kitchens
if they had to they're,
you know, standing
up in front tanks,
they're, you know,
picking up guns
from anywhere and they're
fighting back for their freedom
and fighting back
for their country.
We should take a
lesson from them,
on how much they are doing
to protect being free,
how precious being
free actually is.
And so I think Putin's
absolutely taken back.
And I think Xi sees
Putin is sloppy.
I think that he's looking
at how Putin did this
and he is looking at
Putin made mistakes,
but the way President Xi
is looking at this is,
he's very much paying
attention to every country
that's giving Ukraine arms,
he's paying attention
to every company
that's no longer doing
business with Russia.
He's watching what's
happening at the UN.
He's watching how the
world is isolating Russia.
And he is not saying, no,
I'm not gonna do this.
He's saying, okay,
when I do this,
I'm gonna have to
do it differently.
And so it, again,
we can't take our
eyes off of China
because China is gonna be next.
What we need to do is
learn the lessons of Russia
and see what happens
when division comes in,
which is what happened
with us and our allies.
When we look distracted,
it opens a door for
these thugs to do,
you know, the devil's work
and that's exactly
what they're doing.
- So if you were still the
ambassador at the UN right now,
if you were the US
ambassador at the UN
and you were sitting apart from,
sitting across the table
from your Russian
counterpart right now,
what would you be saying to him?
Like, how do we get
Putin to turn back?
Like what, what do you
think his off ramp is?
What, what would you be
offering them to say,
'Hey, okay, this thing
got messy for two weeks,
but let's, let's back up now.'
- Well, first of all, Dave,
I would be railing at the
United Nations right now.
I would've been railing
every single day,
to get some attention
towards Ukraine
before this conflict happened,
but also to kind
of rally the world
and to not just saying
you're with Ukraine,
but actually doing
something about it
and having them act.
And the first group that needs
to act are the Europeans,
it's their region,
they need to really step up.
- Did we do anything?
Did we do anything at the UN,
I mean, this was like a slow
motion war for three weeks
where Biden kept saying,
oh, it's gonna happen.
Maybe it'll happen
tomorrow three days.
I mean, were we doing
anything at the UN?
- Oh yes, absolutely.
What America was doing at the UN
was they got back into the
UN Human Rights Council,
you know,
and now they're sitting on
that Human Rights Council,
shoulder with Russia and China,
who Russia's now
committing war crimes.
So Biden neither needs to,
to kick Russia out of
the Human Rights Council
or he needs to get off himself.
America was active at the UN,
in dealing with this Iran deal.
Can you imagine now that
you're gonna go in a room
and negotiate with China
and Russia on, you know,
how to stop Iran from
producing nuclear weapons?
That's a joke and it would,
it's a fireable offense,
if Biden continues to try
and get into this Iran deal.
And so, yeah, they
were doing things,
but they were doing
all the wrong things.
And what they should
have been doing
was rallying the troops,
what they should have been doing
was tough love to the
European saying, stop this.
And you know, one of
the things I did was,
I was constantly beating up
Germany for Nord Stream 2.
And, you know, and we
were constantly saying
this can't happen.
That never should have been
allowed to happen this year.
So there were a
lot of things done,
it just were all
the wrong things.
- So when they have a
resolution at the UN
and one of the countries
that's doing the invading
has veto power,
is it all just theater?
I mean, at the end, like,
is it just sort of
ridiculous theater
because Russia vetoed the
resolution about Russia.
You can't blame
'em for doing that.
- So the interesting
thing is yes,
Russia vetoed the resolution
in the security council,
but what they were able to do
that Russia couldn't
do anything about
was they took it to
the General Assembly,
you know, the 193 countries.
And what happened was, you know,
basically the world
condemned Russia,
there were only five countries
on the side of Russia,
Russia included, but Russia
stood there with Syria,
North Korea.
Those are not friends
you wanna be sitting
on the corner with,
and that's who they were.
And so, yeah, they did that,
but at the end of the day,
what does a resolution do?
Right?
So yes, it's, you know,
you're condemning,
you're telling Russia,
you're a bad, you gotta stop,
but it's not doing anything.
And so, you know, there
goes to my frustration
with the United Nations is,
you know, saying something
and acting that's great.
Now what?
you know, now we get to perform.
- So what does a sane resolution
of this situation
look like to you?
I mean, is this something
that we're just gonna be sort
of slowly in for a long time?
Is there something that
we can do to give Putin
that off ramp so that he
doesn't have to escalate?
What is an actual out
of this look like?
- Well, I think look at
the environment, right?
So you've got Ukrainians
taking to the streets
to defend themselves.
You've got Russians.
It's pretty ironic that you've
got thousands of Russians
taking to the streets of
Russia, protesting Putin,
extremely courageous,
because they know that
they'll be killed.
They know that they'll
be jailed for doing that.
You've got, you know,
the Europeans really stepping
up at a time to help Ukraine.
I think that you're gonna see,
Russia's gonna continue
to take Ukraine by force.
I think they're gonna kind of
sit on the barrier for a while
and try and see how much
progress they can make.
But at the end of the day,
Putin's gonna try and put
one of his own lackeys
in government, you
know, in Ukraine,
but the Ukrainian people,
aren't gonna go for that.
I mean, I think
you've seen the spirit
of the Ukrainian people,
They're not ever go for that.
So Putin's gotta
figure this out.
You know, he's already
become a pry in the world.
He's isolating himself, So
he's already very paranoid.
I think he's worried about
being eliminated himself.
We know that he's trying
to eliminate Zelenskyy.
So, you know, I think
this isn't gonna be done
in a couple of days.
The sad part is,
the media is gonna
get tired of this.
The media's not gonna have
constant Ukraine shots
and everybody else is gonna
go back to their business,
but the bloodshed's
not gonna stop.
And I think this is
gonna last a while.
- Yeah, I'm glad you mentioned
the media part of this
because I feel that it's my
job to just sort of translate
some of this stuff
to my audience
and bring on people like you,
who are the experts in this
so that they can get an
honest assessment of this.
One of the things that I'm
really struggling with right now
is who to trust.
You know, I've lost such
trust in our corporate press
that, you know,
it's very hard for me to
pick up the New York times
that I feel lies
about so many things
and say, oh,
but this is the thing
they're telling the truth on.
How do you, I mean,
is it just from talking
to a other ambassadors
and talking to
people on the ground,
how do you get news
that make sense to you?
- I read a lot
and I read a lot of
different sources
and I do,
I have been in conversations
with my counterpart
at the United
Nations from Ukraine
who's now back in Ukraine.
You know, we're
talking to people
who have families on
the ground in Russia.
You know, you just,
you read as much as you can
and you take all the
opinions out of it.
That's the key.
You know, the media wants
to tell you what to think.
You don't need to
know what to think.
You need to know the facts.
And then you put together
what you think on your own.
And so, you know, you
can't read too much,
but the media, at this
point, I will say the media,
at least they're covering
Ukraine in what is a fair way.
They're not trying to, you
know, rosy up on Putin.
They're calling him
the thug that he is.
They're showing the
bloodshed that's happening.
They're highlighting Zelenskyy
and the brave people of Ukraine.
And I think that's
what we need to see,
but you know, the media
hasn't been an outlet to trust
for a very long time.
- Do you think that if it was
the guy that you worked for,
President Trump and this
was happening right now
that the media would be
treating this the same?
I mean, it seems
fairly obvious to me
that the media would be,
everything would be at the
footsteps of America right now.
And this is what
Trump brought upon us.
I mean, you can actually
see them doing some of that,
blaming Trump for this.
Psaki, you know, you probably
saw that line the other day
where she said,
there's a pattern here,
of Putin invading Ukraine.
She forgot that the thing
that broke the pattern
was the four years under Trump.
- You know, it's
interesting because I've,
I've have always told everybody,
you know, the four years
that President Trump had,
he never got an ounce of peace
or one bit of credit
through all four years.
He was hammered
every day, all day.
And he didn't have Afghanistan.
He didn't have the Ukraine mess.
He didn't have
inflation like this.
He didn't have the
crime in the streets,
he didn't have all that.
And they still beat up on him.
And then, you know,
to go have them hail Biden's
State of the Union speech
as this amazing unifier.
You know, it wasn't that.
All it was was a
lot of Republican
talking points saying,
you know, we've gotta get
rid of crime on the streets.
We've gotta put
kids back in school.
We have choose
freedom over tyranny.
You know, we've got
to fund the police.
Well, guess what?
We've been saying
that this entire year
that Biden's been in office
and now he's saying it,
but you, he didn't offer one
solution, not one solution.
And you know, the
only solution Dave,
is to win the races in 2022,
we've gotta take back the House.
We've gotta take
back the Senate.
We've got 36 governors races.
And if you ever saw
the importance of a
governor, you know,
you saw it during COVID
and you saw some fantastic
Republican governors
go and protect their people.
And I think that we've
gotta really make sure
that we put a stop to all of
this progressive extremism
that we're seeing
come out of the Left
and, you know, stop
Biden and try and,
you know, say a
prayer along the way,
because it's gonna be
a long three years.
- Not only do I know it,
but as you know, I'm living it
because I am in the free
state of Florida right now,
not at my home in Cali anymore.
We only have a
couple minutes left,
but let's just go with the,
the political part of this,
for just a bit.
Does it drive you crazy
like when you watch
the State of the Union
and Biden basically starts
repeating the things
that Republicans, Conservatives,
whatever have been
saying for years.
Oh, now we have to
fund the police.
We have to get kids back
in school, et cetera.
Does it drive you nuts that,
that they can always
get away with it?
That's where I'm really
hung up at the moment.
Like they're getting
away with it.
And I think by October,
they're gonna have
people believing
that it was Republicans
who wanted lockdowns
and Republicans
who wanted mandates
and Republicans who wanted
to defund the police,
et cetera, et cetera.
- They're not gonna
get away with it Dave.
- I hope you're right.
- The American
public is too smart.
The American people
are too smart.
I was campaigning for
Glenn Youngkin in Virginia.
I was campaigning for Jack
Ciattarelli in New Jersey.
And we only lost that race
by one percentage point.
And I'm telling you the
frustration on the ground
in Virginia was no different
than the frustration on
the ground in New Jersey.
And what you saw were,
you saw Independents and
Conservative Democrats say
we've had enough.
They were tired of
what was happening
to their kids in schools.
They're tired of seeing
all these mandates.
They were tired of seeing
the crime in their streets
and they're each, you know,
every family is paying more
than $250 more a month.
That's a lot.
So, no, I don't think
the American people
will fall for this.
And I think they'll show it
when we come November in 2022
and we win all these races back.
- All right ambassador,
I only have--
- That means we have to
prove we deserve to be there
when we get there.
- Yeah, well, absolutely.
So I only have one
more question for you.
It's the question you
definitely don't want,
but because I'm on the
record as saying that
I want DeSantis to
stay here in Florida,
because I believe that those
governorships are so important.
There is a
Presidential Election,
after the other thing,
I kind of asked y'all last time.
I mean, how you feeling,
obviously you're not thrilled
with worldwide leadership
at the moment,
and there's gonna be a
really wide ranging crop.
Whoever is in it.
I'm excited for
the Republican crop
because I do sense it's gonna
be a lot of new, fresh blood,
and there'll be a sort of
wide variety of voices.
Are you thinking
about it at all?
- Well, I think
that there is no 24,
if we don't win in 2022,
but I don't think I
have to make a decision
until the first part of 23.
I can tell you, I've
never lost a race.
I'm not gonna start now.
So if there's a place
for me, then we'll move.
If there's not,
I'm gonna fight for America
for as long as I can
and make sure that we
do whatever we need to.
The beauty of it is,
is the Republican
bench as strong.
We've got a lot of
talent on our bench.
The Democrat bench, not so much.
- The current situation with
them ain't so great either.
Ambassador Haley,
I appreciate you taking the time
and hopefully we can do this
in person sometimes soon.
- Thanks so much, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.